[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of Rissa fury I'm Kelsey cook and today
I can't wait to play this person I'm so
excited I have on dr. Drew yes yeah
we're here that's my camera hi everybody
just cuz you want to kick my ass this
would be great awesome
here we go I feel like you told me that
you wanted to play I do because I
haven't played since I was about 14 and
I'd be curious to see what I can do and
so you have some experience that were
you good back then I mean not on a table
like this though I dig though the weight
of this table it's so different right
it's different yeah I mean the you know
when kids play sometimes they'll do this
business and you almost can't do that
with this yeah I know you won't I will
not do it but it levels can because
they're so you wouldn't want to the way
they're weighted out there's some really
shitty tables out there that are just
like a feeling you could lift them with
one yeah and that's I don't even
consider that it I know that violates
your Sensibility really you're just
there are few things out there that hurt
you as much as that virtual sets me if I
go to like a bar and there's a table
that just looks like like a shelter
animal where it's just like covered in
and I've gone and I've been like do
you have some paper towels and some Pam
and I will whole career here save the
foosball tables or in school yeah that's
what I'm talking about
yeah it upsets me so we try to keep this
table nice okay so you have some
personal experience are you competitive
yeah it can't be except when I get blown
away then I give up quickly so okay
don't be too tough on me okay
[Music]
so we're gonna play the first game to
five won't this talk we'll have a good
time and then after that we'll kind of
do some other things that do some other
things bizarre but yeah you'll see
alright so but I don't want I don't just
put the ball in and just slam went in I
was gonna tell you suddenly the
regulation playing out is that you set
it on your on your five bar you asked
your opponent ready
they say ready and then you're supposed
to touch the ball to two men wait a
second and then hit it so there's no
wild I got it okay
you get the ball first course okay right
you get it first do you know no you get
it first you sure yeah that's how you
set it up okay okay are you ready I'm
ready
okay so I've done your podcast dr. drew
after dark a couple times
oh god damn it I hate I hate those
slam shots alright people by the way
you're very like emotionally you know
like a very stout when I play foosball
are you ready I'm ready
and I go back and forth mm-hmm and then
yeah you're gonna go um so my second
episode with you is that intentional or
was that did I just do that you see what
you're walking into
yeah so my second episode okay yeah my
mother came out today because yes you
wanted to have me back on because
there'd been like a controversy about a
car trip we asked I will the controversy
we played it's Han we're gonna do some
other stuff so I hate to see what that's
gonna be
you ready yes so it wasn't controversy
so much I knew don't do that how do you
[Applause]
so annoying
your parents are better than you well my
mom's in the face ball Hall of Fame so
she's she's unplanned for 40 years but
if she and I play each other at a
tournament now it's kind of like 5050
like I'll beat her Wow bad no family I
learned learned everybody yes yeah I got
it finally into the back field here so I
came on your show the first time what
was that talked about you did something
funny there yeah what's that all about
just like recess for fun just get that
were used yeah so I came on so that was
good time go ahead
get on the show because we've talked
about being multi-orgasmic and I knew
that would piss off a bunch of women
because they get really weird about that
lo and behold this huge huge
conversation occurred and I didn't
realize that I could come back come back
had a great time and then apparently
since I left you were getting a bunch of
messages of people saying that over the
place including my own wife everybody
had an opinion see your own wife thought
she's making it a bit more else's life
and just you were just that's it's
always where the non that's where the
average female yeah yeah right
needs some sort of direct stimulation
and can only have one orgasm and has a
refractor phase and so when somebody
brings up this other biology they just
go she's lying she's bragging she's
distorting that's not really happening
they have all kinds of explanations
right and people like yourself are even
more sore like yourself think the common
woman is just sort of hasn't figured it
out yet is don't know what they're doing
right right and so I'm and I'm not that
where when I hear about women who
struggle to have an orgasm have to do a
bunch of crazy weird in order to
come I'm not like well they just don't
know what it's like easy what's
matter I would never think that I just
know a lot but I've heard more women
going it's it's distorted denying what
happens with you
just tonight and I knew I knew when you
said that I wouldn't have kind of
reaction but it was a big reaction so I
thought we got to revisit this so crazy
it's such a weird thing you're T want I
just think that such a weird
to lie about but we talked on the
podcast how so I'm allergic to
everything
oh yeah this is how karma balances how
God is yeah like let me come a bunch of
times because I can't eat a
Snickers bar like let me have something
yeah so there are people aren't okay
with what we that you let's see your
your podcast let me just went up where
you made that proposal let's see what
the reaction is I think I think we got
deep enough into the conversation that
when we're gonna just listen and learn
and then start so sorry for your
allergies well really feel sorry for
your your your originals the first time
I tried master videos yeah you guys
don't know it's it's the stories on
YouTube for this is not happening on
Comedy Central that the first time I
tried masturbating I used my mom's
handheld manicure tool that was shaped
like a dick but it was made of rubber
latex
okay the custom and the part that I find
cringe-worthy is you having to go to
your mom works and then the ER and then
and tell the doctor in the ER your
family doctor 14 or 15 oh yeah 15 how
did you get over those I mean just for
me just just talk about the trauma so
much doesn't bother you anymore yeah I
mean that happened I was 15 I started
talking about it on stage probably I was
like 25 and then if you can make people
laugh about really close
yeah and then you hear other people so I
wanted to ask you before we get to the
next round
what is the weirdest thing you've heard
about somebody putting either in their
vagina or their or their
sure well that seems to be where people
put the most bizarre stuff right women
are a little bit dainty er about all
this because the the the rectum sends to
be the domain of the mayor you saw what
that looked like after it had an
allergic reaction to it I don't think
you call it dainty like that was not a
good but yeah we used to see stuff in
the ER all the time right forgot calls I
mean that you work in an ER more than a
couple weeks you'll see somebody with
some of their ass what's the weirdest
thing though well the the weird is a
part of
I saw you know vibrators routinely like
that went too far up we have to retrieve
a guy with a was a grapefruit like a
fruit and use it grateful yeah yeah yeah
and they go the broomstick and but those
and everything here's here's the
craziness this is the comedy so it's
some foreign body that I mean was I
think some of these things were somebody
like was like a drug deal gone bad and
they say like we're gonna here's what
we're gonna do to you if you don't pay
me and then they do it
I think that's against their well oh
yeah some of that stuff cuz it's over
needed surgery it some people die you
know they they puncture their coal on a
stuff yeah yeah so so but but the comedy
if there is a comedy on this when you
ask them what happened they except for
the vibrators they will always say the
same thing why I guess triptan yeah that
was that was back in the 80s things were
simpler then I don't know whose ass hole
is so gaping that you could sit out
great for you know it envelops it right
that would not happen and so it's just
like every time somebody got stabbed
every every stab wound I saw and I saw
hundreds was some due to the buck knife
some do to the bug back that was the
answer to that well who did it what
happened some do the buck knife had
their thinking up your house I sat on it
stop asking your life the things that
fill your brain thank you thank your
president
[Music]
we're gonna do a second round now so
come on over here we're gonna do some
things to make it easier for you to beat
me
that's not possible clearly not gonna
happen we'll see what am i doing okay so
grab one all right and tell me what
number is on there one two is that one
or two - that's it - yep I got one okay
so you get a 3 point headstart like
that's gonna do anything and so we we
customize this because you were coming
on we've never done anything like this
we're gonna we bought a bunch of
vibrating dildos and we're gonna attach
them to my rods and turn them on and I
have to play with it vibrating what is
this pinecone situation down here who's
this for this is gigantic how do you
turn this on
this is industr this is for like the
biggest gangbang of all time who needs
this much maybe colonoscopy lab she's
the PA said it was somebody there was
night this was $90 Jesus it was not $90
this is $90 we're not even using this
like for my this is just for
like hands this is such a waste
wow this is no beating oh Christ
so I'm training these on go ahead and
take three points what sorry
why bother and
the thing was that's like it's like
industrial-strength my hands are you
having trouble holding on this side of
the table oh my god this is like what I
talked about on your phone yeah if I put
this to me I would like puree my
like this is this is for industrial
kitchens for sure okay so I'm gonna ask
you some of the questions that people
wrote in on Instagram story as we play
all right all right what in the is
my life right now I'm yours
okay so can we get to the bottom of if
squirt is P ah
what's your what's your when you come in
on that one well I have never squirted
but I have heard from people who have
that it's like pee but more watery so
you can move it like move the ball yeah
I just do that
so there are two different things
okay there are people at P called female
orgasmic and continents in that case
it's belong P and that's for a fair
number of people but that's why don't I
get up my own way yeah that's a fair
number of people but more than that it
is so I never get my defensive stance
that's the problem yeah it is
there are women that actually there's a
gland called the Perry refill and in the
mail turns into the prostate other women
sometimes have a tissue there that will
actually produce fluid that's kind of
like pressed you ready oh yes kind of
like prosthetic ready ready kind of like
prostatic fluid see all right block I'd
do more difference for you and you think
that you okay so it's it's a gland
perico gland that produces a and not
everyone can do that that's much like
your talent it's a special version
people can teach themselves how to
support me on jessiemae Peluso come on
and say that she
taught herself how to squirt some people
maybe you got to have that gland and
it's got to be a producing enough fluid
to be able to do that and that's not
everybody okay so some people just
biologically will never be able to
correct you're interesting okay we have
officially debunked its so it's not Pete
it can be and then it's female orgasmic
incontinence and some people do that but
what's the fluid if it's the gland it's
it's and it's got a name repair you'll
reach for Perry to Yuri through fluid
okay interesting you're really like the
Bill Nye have coming like I'm learning
so much from you okay so people can
write unit about your rule about nothing
bigger than the okay symbol oh yeah can
go in your right that was show
one of after dark and I think Segura was
with me okay I'm not ready yet and he
did somebody asked the question like I
just said just generally just nothing
okay sign just leave it at that right
god damn it oh right like that's gonna
make any difference
oh my god I'm gonna die with this Lube
on my hands like this will never come
off it's so greasy
hey ended one ball gown I've made one
shot on goal this is gonna be a Friday
game okay
somebody was asking it as like a
challenge question like how can you but
you can go bigger I mean obviously yes
but you're saying in general yeah I just
said it's a rule of thumb and how about
we how about we just say that okay
somebody wants okay I need a I need a
focus I forgot that you started with
somebody somebody wants to know how you
feel about squatty potty's agnostic if
it helps you and congratulation I'm like
you know I do not use one I'm not sure
they're so necessary but I bought it I
like hurt my you tried one like my ass
bones because it's pushing your knees up
and then it's like it's just so much
pressure a toilet yeah yeah that makes
sense to me what's the worst thing that
Tom Segura has ever made you watch a lot
of bad things the two that did jump out
at me
they had one guy like a mechanic
bringing a car into a you know into a
bay and the car kept going just slams
right into him and essentially cut his
legs off I Tom thought that was so funny
and I was like I just I said that's a
dead person well they actually looked
into it the guy survived just had
terrible hysterical and and then there
was the I think you watch the pool
right didn't you oh yeah yeah I'll never
forget it I won't either that's the
other one some guy dumpster diving with
a leather you know not a sewer
accessible just just filled with it
was like how this dude came we think we
think but thank you Tom and Christina
for making my life so much richer here
you go ready another person wrote in
asking how auto-erotic asphyxiation a
fixation
yes fixation why that makes orgasm so
much because when you cut the blocks
chain off to your head yeah you get your
brain gets just before you die
you know when you see the white light
itself your brain gets flooded with a
bunch of door
often things that make everything more
intense and so choking is like the mild
version of that that's the same idea
same idea what's this move what's that
all about I don't know it's just feeling
if it hits it then it goes back for this
so yeah we talked about on your podcast
that that like this is too too intense
for me you feel like that's pretty good
puree I think yeah I think did it you
want I think women are more nuanced than
men understand Joe yeah Wow well that
was the first
[Music]
okay well well the we take these off I'm
gonna tell you that for the third and
final round we're gonna play two ball
we're just we each have a ball we'd have
our own time a bomb and we say one two
three go
and we hit it and then you have to score
both balls to get one point okay so
you're playing essentially offense and
defense simultaneous yes and if we each
score one assist or wash okay so I told
you you know we asked about Tom showing
you crazy videos yeah
which then you know you do that on your
show yeah they send them over to my show
okay people were so happy with me being
humiliated and upset watching those
videos we made a whole show about it you
seem to really like be delighted by them
like it seems to bring you a lot of joy
to the guest reactions are fun and
interesting but the videos make me very
sad well make me actually I'm you're
very sad well what we're gonna do today
has a little bit of money back for you
making me watch these horrible videos on
your show is we're gonna pull up the
cake fart video which you've seen
apparently you haven't seen this thing
so good thank you maybe you've seen
thank you it so it's a woman farting
into account you know low love line
partners to play okay so we're gonna
make you watch a video of a woman
farting into a cake over and over while
you eat cake you're gonna know carb
diet' make me vegetables or something
something damn it okay well we'll make
you eat them yeah maybe something and
then also we're gonna pull up the video
that you made me watch with you of the
woman drinking her own urine while you
drink some Gatorade okay I'm good
some lemon-lime Gatorade you okay with
that I'm good with that okay so somebody
wrote in and says is vaginismus real and
how would it be treated well is that it
is what you had when you had your
allergic reaction it's a spasm of the
vaginal musculature and it really hurts
and it's think it's funny I won lobby I
mean that didn't happen to be right I
don't know if it was that it was just
like a severe well it was the veggies
was followed all their swelling
and but somebody would get it for
various reasons and it's a spinal reflex
essentially and they have to get
physical therapy to get out of it where
their just tightens up yeah and
they guys hurts when they when they turn
to penetrate lots of reasons for it but
I feel like that's like every dudes
dream though you know no can't can't
penetrate you cannot get in not without
real pain I mean men are bad they're not
that bad typically this mean like every
you know every guys but that's I didn't
realize that was even possible
mmm Padgett is most worried about it
another thing they you've never had
right except when you introduce electric
toothbrushes or whatever you're wearing
it was it
I did try a Sonicare at one point though
before that oh good that worked right
latex about that I was 15 what am I
doing here I'm watching you are you
ready yeah one two three go Oh going in
you created this thing where you have to
do too many things once goddamnit okay
okay somebody also has do you agree with
Adam Carolla's theory about little girl
voice is there it's I that was that was
I showed him that Oh
okay so what is one two three yeah
people get arrested at certain stages of
development when they have trauma and it
and it affects you you can I kicked that
one in you if you close your eyes you
can hear the aged little like you're
talking to a person who's the age you
can tell which aids they were
traumatized because they just they just
stopped developing whoa how's
developmental arrests so we used to sew
on Loveline we used to bet we'd hear the
voice and we go all right to hold on put
her on hold we go let's bet what was the
age which she was traumatized and we
were never we were rarely long Wow yeah
I've never heard that before that mean
that makes sense
yeah all right ready one two three go
so unfair it's like why don't we just
play pro football with you no I mean
again you wanted to come on the show I
guess I do I did I did
I thought it was being nice quid pro quo
like ready one two three go
little did I know though it's just gonna
be had taken advantage of I'll always be
super nice be on your show but what
people don't want to watch me be nicer
yeah I still have this goddamn $90 lobe
on my hands is that wise $90 vol not for
the type Christ give it right back to
you alright okay two more points and
then it's Gatorade couriers times we
ought to go back and forth you know okay
one two three go come on
so what did you what did your wife say
after after this after this podcast you
did yeah after the more recent one right
she had hurry up other thing right now
she's flying back for New Orleans and I
bet she's listening to it doing what
definitely you have to let me know if
she's still not convinced that's good
that would be interesting then I'll
bring you both on do you talk about your
sex life on your shows or usually not
particularly did you get to in know you
had yeah that's interesting because I
feel like you know your job is so
getting each other but I mean I look I'm
an internist right and if we just
started got into it to talk about AIDS
and I just was there asking answering
any questions that came along and all
this other came well that's it
Segura so I'm really just talking about
love line we'll wait
you do that and love Lyon people just
had questions and so I just answer
themselves but you you've been when
you're right for 30 years
mmm that's amazing we've been married
for 20 no I mean I think 28 and then
we've got together like 35 or something
Wow crazy so clearly you you know you
guys know what you're doing you're doing
like everything it is good that's
awesome wait am I crazy that it's good
after all those jeez that's weird
yeah yeah that's kind of crazy so I
recommend that I want to ask you so many
questions go ahead you know and you'll
answer about your sex life
are you guys like kinky into like some
kind of weird
not really okay I mean no no he sucks me
tired out but that's about it
okay I don't understand that I don't
understand that at all so it's hard to
participate in that do you have any like
weird fetishes me yeah no nothing
mm-hmm mm-hmm sorry about that I feel
like maybe like can I ask you like what
your go-to porn is again priest and a
priest standard stuff and attractive
people yeah that's about it for me okay
here we'll keep playing for one two
three go
somebody wrote any interesting weird um
where do foot fetishes come from like
why nobody knows that's kind of
interesting that's not understood people
have various theories about it one is
that there you go one of the arousal
centers is near it's sort of where we
perceive you know sort of motor neuron
feet and another theory is that it's you
know during childhood highly arousing
traumatic experiences yeah tend to occur
when you're way down here and so if
maybe somehow wires in some yeah so
nobody knows bottom line it's pretty
weird though a lot of foot stuff out
there yeah I'm on wiki feet I didn't
know that but I am and I I think I only
have like a 3.2 out of 5 stars like it's
a real it's like an Applebees feet sort
of situation it's not I kind of wish I
hadn't loved of it here we go ready 1 2
three go yeah a guy at me a message and
said like $2,000 for footbed and I was
very tempted yeah
he was dinner right I didn't because I
feel it's like the whole violation was
like if you give a moose a muffin
you remember that childhood book it's
like I give him the foot video something
else is gonna start from the same guy or
some other or you're you're you're gonna
go down some row where you're giving
that's a nice chunk of change right but
yeah I feel like you would want more
than that maybe anything but just like
very doctor and come on I love watching
oh that's so much fun for me good that
made you happy
no it's not fun for me yeah yes it was a
little bit fun as I'm fun things go
getting your ass handed to you that's
true well now we're gonna make it a
little more unfun you're gonna drink
some Gatorade is that okay with your
partner I'll deal with it just like you
said yeah this is just a 30-second clip
of it says girl drinking her friend's
piss what is wrong with people
Anna okay so you have to drink as she
drinks it Cheers oh my god it does it
does really weirdly oh my god okay there
you go doing and Robert good man why is
this so hard for Anna that's providing
the pen like one job to do and then you
drink it
I like the way Kelsey because you were
watching like you know it's not a fake
yeah it's so weird
yeah it's so weird that it gets you like
that well thank you well good I didn't
vomit it's good Rachel's disappointed I
was ready we're gonna drink it and feel
like it wasn't hydrate hydrate mm-hmm I
thought you would just breeze through it
and then that was gonna be kind of like
anti-climatic but I'm no yeah no you
show me gross
well to be fair you primed if I make me
look at 60 other terrible video Rachel's
manual porn okay whom do i plug to plug
to middle camp middle camera so
everything's really at dr. Drew calm or
dr. Drew TV I do a Staley streaming show
now we're just an scruples questions
they tend to be kind of medical and
mental health type stuff and then on
Sundays typically we do a call-in show
again straightening on all the platforms
twitch facebook anywhere to watch for
them if you sign in for dr. calm you'll
get a little blast out or dr. Drew TV
and then the dr. Drew and Adam and drew
and then the after dark which is what
Kelsey did which is people seem to like
that podcast it's so fun it is a fun one
it's all bunch of comedians and their
stuff so please go listen to that you
guys can follow me on instagram at
Kelsey cook comedy Twitter's at Kelsey
cook website is Kelsey cook calm for
tour dates and please subscribe to the
all things comedy youtube channel give
this video a thumbs up watch the other
episodes and we'll see you guys next
time
don't ever play Kelsey if we fall don't
ever do that thank you guys for watching
another episode of erisa fury be sure to
pick up your official erisa fury shirts
that they are buttery soft they feel
like Dalton skin they're lovely be sure
to LIKE and subscribe to the all things
comedy channel and you can get the
shirts at the link below
free shipping
[Music]
you